en el último vídeo empezamos a construir
un diagrama de espacio-tiempo para mi
marco de referencia verdad y yo solo me
hallaba a la deriva en el espacio y
supuse que me encontraba en un marco de
referencia inercial es decir que me
muevo a una velocidad constante respecto
a cualquier otro marco de referencia y
planteamos una situación donde yo emití
un fotón al tiempo de igual a cero
verdad y entonces dibujamos su
trayectoria verdad y vimos que al tiempo
un segundo entonces ese fotón habría
recorrido 3 por 10 a la 8 metros después
de dos segundos habría recorrido 6 por
10 a la 8 metros y después de tres
segundos habría recorrido 9 por 10 a la
8 metros y también supusimos verdad
vemos la situación en donde había una
nave espacial en donde había una amiga
mía dentro de ella y esa nave espacial
se movía a 0.5 de verdad donde se era la
velocidad
la luz muy bien entonces igual dibujamos
su trayectoria aquí dibujamos su
trayectoria y vimos que después de un
segundo ella habría recorrido 1.5 por 10
a la 8 metros después de dos segundos
ella habría recorrido 3 por 10 a la 8
metros y después de tres segundos ella
habría recorrido 4.5 por 10 a la 8
metros y así sucesivamente verdad
entonces aquí vamos a dibujar su nave
digamos esta es su nave al tiempo de
igual a cero es decir al tiempo que
igual a cero se encuentra en la misma
posición que yo verdad pero ahora
digamos que a 3 por 10 a la 8 metros se
encuentra otra nave espacial enfrente de
ella que también se va a mover ok va a
ir viajando en la misma dirección a 1.5
por 10 a la 8 metros por segundo es
decir
a la misma dirección que la nave
espacial de mi amiga verdad entonces
estamos concluyendo con esto que va a la
misma velocidad relativa a mi verdad a
la misma velocidad que mi amiga relativa
a mí pero desde su punto de vista
parecerán estacionarios porque la
distancia entre ellos permanecerá igual
verdad entonces si esperamos dos
segundos por ejemplo si esperamos dos
segundos
esta nave entonces ya estará a 6 por 10
a la 8 metros verdad entonces encontrar
aquí y podemos trazar nuestra
trayectoria voy a hacerlo un poquito más
grueso podemos trazar la trayectoria
verdad en este diagrama y lo que
esencialmente estaré haciendo aquí es
crear una cuadrícula para el marco de
referencia de mi amiga que pondré sobre
él sobre el marco de referencia mío que
ya había puesto en el vídeo anterior y
para hacer claros no estamos suponiendo
en este vídeo la relatividad especial
sino sólo mecánica clásica es decir el
mundo newton
la verdad y esto lo vamos a utilizar
para dejar claras las ideas y ver dónde
es que se viene abajo el mundo
newtoniano así que ahora digamos que hay
otra nave por aquí que se encuentra a 6
por 10 a la 8 metros de la nave de mi
amiga verdad que justamente era donde yo
me encontraba verdad y si dejamos pasar
un segundo verdad entonces si van a la
misma velocidad que las otras dos naves
entonces éste estará a 7.5 por 10 a la 8
metros verdad si dejamos pasar dos
segundos entonces se encontrará a nueve
por diez a la ocho metros muy bien
entonces vamos a con esto ya podemos
dibujar su trayectoria verdad vamos a
dibujar su trayectoria y será más o
menos
así muy bien entonces podemos observar
que estas rectas son justamente
paralelas y así es como vamos a ir
construyendo nuestra cuadrícula muy bien
entonces
vamos a montar el marco de referencia de
mi amiga y ese marco de referencia vamos
a llamarle digamos que sería el eje x
prima esto está muy grueso vamos a poner
x prima será el eje del marco de
referencia de mi amiga y este eje de
aquí ahora verdad si este es el digamos
la trayectoria que recorre la nave de mi
amiga entonces este será el eje de prima
muy bien entonces sólo voy a marcar
ahora de nuevo este mismo eje x pero con
color azul claro para que quede claro
que también es el eje x prima muy bien
ahí lo tenemos y pues vamos a tener
también que ponerle nombre verdad por
ejemplo si el marco de referencia en
donde yo me encontraba el en el marco
ese vamos a llamarle al marco de
referencia de mi amiga el marco s prima
muy bien entonces vamos a poner también
las referencias de los segundos
esta primera línea horizontal esta
segunda línea horizontal más o menos y
esta tercera línea horizontal muy bien
ahí está muy bien entonces ahora vamos a
asegurarnos de que podemos leer bien lo
que estamos viendo aquí entonces
consideremos por ejemplo este primer
punto de aquí este punto de aquí vamos a
considerarlo y vamos a tratar de definir
cuáles son las coordenadas desde mi
marco de referencia muy bien entonces
podríamos observar que aquí si digamos
bajamos bajamos verticalmente para saber
dónde corta aquí podemos ver que llega a
4.5 por 10 a la 8 metros verdad si lo
ponemos con con unidades mientras que
eso sería en la dirección x verdad en
este eje mientras que digamos la altura
que se refiere al eje t verdad sera
segundo entonces estas son las
coordenadas de este punto desde mi marco
de referencia que es ese muy bien ahora
como como lo vemos desde el marco de
referencia de mi amiga veamos cuál
serían sus coordenadas desde el marco de
referencia de mi amiga bueno pues si
observamos aquí también nos encontramos
en un segundo la segunda coordenada
sería un segundo verdad desde el marco
de referencia de mi amiga pero ahora
vamos a tener que bajar a lo largo de
esta línea
si queremos verlo en el marco de
referencia de ella verdad y entonces
vemos que llegamos a tres por diez a la
ocho metros bien 3 por 10 a la 8 metros
y esa sería su coordenada en el eje en
este caso estaríamos hablando del eje x
prima muy bien
en realidad podemos ver este punto
verdad como como el lugar donde se
hallaba la segunda nave después de un
segundo y desde el punto de vista de mi
amiga sigue a tres por diez a la ocho
metros de ella verdad si simplemente
parecían estacionarios lo habíamos
mencionado entonces esto será cierto
igual por ejemplo cuando hablamos de dos
segundos tres segundos porque se mueven
a la misma velocidad y en la misma
dirección cierto entonces parecerán
estacionarios en esencial solo hemos
doblado este eje vertical verdad lo
hemos digamos inclinado hacia esta línea
azul para poder leer las coordenadas
entonces de hecho por ejemplo aquí
estará también un segundo acá estará dos
segundos acá estará tres segundos
verdad en realidad hemos convertido la
rejilla original que son cuadrados como
estamos acostumbrados a leer las
coordenadas verdad lo hemos convertido
en una rejilla de paralelogramo muy bien
y para leer las coordenadas por ejemplo
acaso en mi marco de referencia nosotros
tenemos que bajar verticalmente y vemos
dónde es que intersecta al eje x verdad
pero si hablamos del marco de referencia
de ella entonces tenemos que bajar
paralelamente verdad al eje de prima y
nuevamente vemos dónde es que cruza en
el eje horizontal muy bien para obtener
su coordenada x prima entonces esto nos
da una relación entre las coordenadas
originales verdad las coordenadas x y t
con con las coordenadas nuevas que
serían las coordenadas x prima y t prima
entonces por ejemplo podemos ver que la
coordenada t de mi marco de referencia
será exactamente la misma verdad que la
de mi amiga es decir t será igual a t
prima o lo podemos poner también de esta
forma verdad que prima es igual a t
ahora cuál sería la relación entre x
prima y las coordenadas originales quien
sería x prima en términos de las
coordenadas originales entonces pensemos
nuevamente en este punto verdad aquí nos
encontramos en las coordenadas
originales 4.5 por 10 a la 8 metros
verdad y si nos fijamos con respecto a
la coordenada en el otro marco de
referencia esto es 3 por 10 a la 8
metros entonces uno diría que hay que
tomar la coordenada original y restarle
1.5 por 10 a la 8 metros verdad pero en
realidad esto no es así porque hay que
modificarlo en realidad si vamos
aumentando el tiempo entonces hay que
restar más unidades cierto entonces hay
que restar más unidades en realidad esto
sería metros sobre segundo y esto hay
que multiplicarlo por el tiempo así que
vamos a ver que esto es cierto entonces
por ejemplo cuando t es igual a un
segundo verdad un segundo se cancelarían
los segundos y nos queda la coordenada
original que es 4.5 por 10 a la 8 metros
menos 1.5 por 10 a la 8 metros y en
efecto nos da 3 por 10
ahora qué pasaría si tomamos este punto
bueno este punto podemos ver que sería 6
por 10 a la 8 verdad la coordenada en mi
marco de referencia entonces sería 6 por
10 a la 8 metros pero en el marco de
referencia de mi amiga seguiría siendo 3
por 10 a la 8 metros verdad estaríamos
justamente sobre esta línea azul
entonces si tomamos la equis original
que son 6 por 10 a la 8 metros y le
restamos dos veces 1.5 por 10 a la 8
metros verdad los segundos se cancelan
nos quedarían tres por 10 a la 8 metros
así que serían 6 por díaz a la 8 metros
menos 3 por 10 a la 8 metros nos da
justamente 3 por 10 a la 8 metros que
era lo que teníamos y esto en principio
puede parecer muy complicado o confuso
pero aquí la clave es que lo dibujes por
tu propia cuenta y trates de graficar
diversos puntos y ver cómo cambian las
coordenadas espacio-temporales en los
distintos marcos de referencia